let's talk about the flip side imagine
you go into a room you feel that
immediacy you feel that energy they love
you great rapport you don't get it
what's your process you call you
follow-up maybe with someone I know a
lot of times they don't let you know you
don't get feedback you really don't and
I I had a wonderful director in New York
woman named Amy salts and I did a play
with her in New Haven at Yale rep and I
was I couldn't get thrown in jail
I just nothing was working and I felt
like I was auditioning really poorly and
so I went to Amy and I said Amy would
you work with me on an audition I've
just I don't know I can't I can't get
hired she says let me do you one better
I'm casting a play at the American place
theater I want you to come sit on our
side of the table and watch those actors
come through an audition for us and so I
did that and I was shocked Karen I was
absolutely shocked because the lesson
that Amy was trying to teach me is that
98% of the time it's not about me it's
about what they need in the project what
they need in the part I watched actors
come in that were not ready to work you
could see them apologize for being there
learned a great lesson from that I
watched actors come in that didn't want
the job they were afraid if they got the
job they would have to do it they were
they were apologetic about being there I
watched actors come in that were
remarkable in the role just remarkable
I mean you you looked at it went oh
that's your guy thank you and they
didn't get the job because they didn't
fit with the vision of the project and
the ensemble that they were trying to
put together it was a great performance
didn't work for this so it really wasn't
about that actor and they had no way of
knowing it if I could have gotten up and
run out of the room and said I can't
tell you how could you
you're not gonna get this job understand
it's not about you
and I couldn't really do that you know
and then I watched actors walked in
there were utterly professional and they
did their work and it was good and it
was solid they said thank you and turned
and walked out and I learned that too
I learned better to have them have to
reach to you to keep you in the room
than you to linger too long get up and
go they'll stop you if they need you and
that was a great lesson for me I found
out that it really wasn't about me I
just need to go back and do my work and
trust that that that would be all night
it would be enough you know keep going
that's interesting that's like that that
psychology of keep them wanting more
yeah
yeah cuz I you know I've done the thing
where you tried to be nice and you
wanted you tried to be winsome oh yeah
you can you guys doing all right and
they're ready to get on they got seven
more guys that they have to see and I
really liked your last project you know
and they're there they're sitting there
thinking how are we going to get this
big leg out of the room and I'm sitting
here thinking if I can sit here long
enough I'll win them over and it doesn't
work that way they're doing a job and
I'm doing a job let's just do our job
and if I can if I did my especially if I
nail the audition I'm out of there
they're gonna they're gonna have to
catch me by the coattail I'm done I'm
gone because I did what I was supposed
to do I did my job and I can't do it any
better I can't do it anymore
I had an experience I with the unit with
David Mamet and I was pretty excited
about auditioning for David and I knew
the character it was it was a guy I knew
the I knew the places in Georgia that
the guy had hunted I knew what his
military bearing was it turned out that
he was a man that was in a wheelchair he
had been paralyzed in a helo accident in
Grenada is based on a true character and
when I was a kid walking home from
football practice there was a guy named
mr. Matlock they would hear me whistling
coming down the street he
he'd been in a railroad accident lost
his legs and he would always come out I
was seven years old he would come out
and he and I would talk
I just stopped there on the corner and
talked to him and he was fascinating to
me because he smoked a pipe and you know
it's a kid you're watching everything
well the ash would fall out of the pipe
and burn a hole in his trousers but of
course his legs were wooden so I never
felt it but I I just unconsciously
studied everything about him so when I
had to play the guy in the wheelchair
when I sat down I was that I was mr.
Matlock I was the guy in the chair and
they didn't get the camera on Karen the
camera there was a new girl who was
working it and moreover I had taken
pages from the script and I said I
appreciate these sides that you've asked
me to read and I'll do that but the
characters over here in this scene and I
gave David his copy of the sides and I
gave a casting director a copy the sides
and I said may I read this and they said
Dave you know Mamet he'll play said sure
in the casting director because David
said sure said sure and but they didn't
get the camera on and I was two hours
away heading to Palm Springs for a
charity golf event and my agents called
and said they didn't get the camera will
you come back and I said no I did what I
could do they were in the room
for either it either happens or it
doesn't but I can't do it any better so
I literally got out of there and didn't
look back
you